quand j'étais petite
il m'arrivait souvent de rêver du feu
le feu est un élément qui nécessite un
frottement
ou un combustible et de l'oxygène
et un jour tout est parti au
[Musique]
Alice c'est ma petite fille elle va
vivre avec nous à partir de maintenant
il y a pas mal d'habitants dans cette
ville qui sont contre l'idée que des
femmes puissent diriger une ferme il
n'apprécie pas qu'on vive coupé du monde
et qu'on soit différente
[Musique]
chance de repartir à zéro Alice la
mairie de cette chance
et on la mérite nous aussi vous croyez
vraiment qu'un lieu où viennent se
réfugier des personnes traumatisées et
le meilleur endroit pour elle elle a
perdu toute sa famille
non ce n'est pas vrai
voiture
il y a des choses que tu dois savoir
des choses que je ne peux pas dire sur
un répondeur
la participer participer à quoi
tu avais l'intention de me le dire
comment tu voulais que je te le dise
ce qu'on va s'enfuir quand même
donc tu nous manques
je lui avais promis de la protéger
mais en dehors d'ici on ne peut pas
fais gaffe il peut y aller
Alice a le droit de savoir ce qu'il
s'est réellement passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas obligé de tout le lui dire
tout de suite
[Musique]